got to look good on camera hey I was
going and welcome to the broken podcast
the best podcast ever [ __ ] my name is
beard pi and witness hey how's it going
we what the [ __ ] welcome to the broken
podcast
I'm Peter pie or something I'm Peter no
wait [ __ ] with me is broken can [ __ ] me
I'm gonna see if we can nail bangs at
this time how's it going guys broken
podcast I wrote it down make sure it's
over I'm so happy
can't you ask mr. curse sorry but you do
not supposed to curse I need to wake the
[ __ ] up you do not supposed to curse
[ __ ] you
that you do not supposed to curse [ __ ]
was that good no it's not my crotch is
still covered in sand so sticky it's so
delicious I have sand in places where
sands shouldn't be I've just realized
whoever and an editor's will hear me
fart I'm so sorry
[Music]
would you just step in slap slap
oh man this looks like I'm doing
something else right now in the middle
you - slap slap did it you ready yeah
[Music]
one two three we jump up 50 feet in the
air for an epic high-five
[Music]